YUFEI ZHAO: OK.
So let's get started.
So we spent quite a bit
of time with graph theory
in the first part
of this course,
and today I want to
move beyond that.
So we're going to talk
about more central topics
and additive
combinatorics, starting
with the Fourier analytic
proof of Roth's theorem.
We discussed Roth's theorem,
and we gave a proof,
during the course, using
similarities, graph regularity
lemma, as well as the
triangle removal lemma.
Today, I want to show
you a different approach
to proving Roth's theorem that
goes through Fourier analysis.
So this is a very
important proof,
and it's one of the main tools
in additive combinatorics.
Let me remind you what
Roth's theorem says.
So Roth proved, in
1953, that if we
write our sub-3 of interval n
to be the maximum size of a 3AP3
subset of 1 through n, then
Roth showed that our 3 of n
is little O of n.
So in other words, if you
have a positive density
subset of the
integers, then it must
contain a three-term
arithmetic progression then.
So what I said is equivalent
to the statement here.
So previously, we gave a
proof using regularity.
Actually the regularity approach
of Szemerédi was only found
the '70s so Roth's original
proof was through Fourier
analysis.
And we'll see that tomorrow.
Today, we'll see a toy
version of this proof.
But it's not really
a toy version.
It has the same ideas, but
in a slightly easier setting
that has fewer technicalities.
But before showing
you that, let me just
discuss a bit of history
around Roth's theorem.
We will show, next
time, the next lecture,
we'll show the bound.
Also by regularity, we get some
bound, which is little O then,
but because of the use
of regularity lemmas,
it's pretty poor dependence.
We got something like
n over log star n.
Next lecture, and basically
Roth's original proof,
gives you a bound which
is n over log-log n.
So it's a much more
reasonable bound.
The current best
upper bound known
has the form, essentially,
n over log n raised to 1
plus little 1,
roughly n over log n.
We do not know, or even
have great guesses on,
what the answer should be.
So the best lower bound,
and this is a construction
that we saw earlier in
the course due to Behrend
is of the form n over
E to the c root log n.
It seems it may be very
difficult to improve
this upper bound without
some genuine new ideas.
On the other hand,
there is some evidence
that the lower bound
might be closer
to the truth in that there are
variants of the Roth problem
for which we know that the lower
bound is basically the truth.
What I want to do today
is look at a variant
of this problem in what's
called a finite field model.
And that basically
just means we're
going to be looking at Roth's
theorem, not in the integers,
but in some finite field
vector space, specifically F3
to the n.
So we're going to define
our sub-3 of this F3
to the n to be the
maximum size of the 3AP3
subset of this finite
field vector space.
So the finite field
model is really useful.
We're going to see this again
later in the course as well.
Many of the ideas
and techniques that
work for the real problem, so to
speak, many of those techniques
also work in the
finite field model,
but they are technically
simpler to execute.
So this is often--
you view it as a sandbox, a
playing ground, for testing out
many of the ideas.
And once you have
those ideas, then you
can see if you can bring
them to the integer setting.
And this is a very
successful program,
and we'll see one aspect of
what happens when we do this.
For this specific problem of
Roth's theorem, in F3 to the n,
there are some nice
interpretations
of what this problem means.
So here's a pretty
easy fact that for--
so n F3 to the n for
three elements, x, y, z,
the following interpretation,
so what it means to be a 3AP,
are equivalent.
So x. y, z form a 3AP.
So 3AP means the y is x
plus D. Z is x plus 2D.
Equivalently, they satisfy this
equation, x minus 2y plus z
equals zero.
OK.
In F3, minus 2 is plus 1.
So it's the same as this
even nicer looking equation,
x plus y plus z equals 2.
It also turns out to be the
same as saying that x, y, z
would lie on a line.
But they are aligned.
So the line has
three points in F3.
And if you look at the
coordinate for every i,
the i-th coordinate of x, y, z
are all distinct or all equal.
So easy to check
all these things
are equivalent to each other.
And the last one is
a nice interpretation
in terms of a game that
many of you know, Set.
So in the game Set, you
have a bunch of cards.
There have some number of
properties, n properties,
like color, the number
of symbols, the shape.
And you want to form
a set being three
cards such that every
property, they're
all same or all different.
So that's exactly
this model over here.
So what can we say
about this problem?
What's the size of
the maximum subset
of F3 to the n-th without 3-AP.
If you look at the proof
that we did earlier
in this course, the one
using triangle removal lemma,
you see the proof
works verbatim.
Previously, we
worked over Z mod n.
Now, you work over a
different group, same proof.
So triangle removal
lemma, it tells you
that this r3 is always little
o of the size of the space.
But we would like to do better.
So this gives you
something like log star.
It's not very good dependence.
So we would like to do better.
So what we will show
today, so this theorem
is attributed to Meshulam.
So in this case, the order of
history is somewhat reversed.
So we'll see the
finite field toy model,
but it historically
actually came afterwards.
But you'll see that the Fourier
analytic proof that we'll
see today, it's basically the
same proof in the two settings.
So F is r3, we will prove a
bound, well, just like that.
So much better than what you
get from the regularity method.
In terms of--
OK, so let me tell you a
bit more about the history
of this problem in
terms of what we
know in terms of upper
bounds and lower bounds.
So let me say more about F3.
So what's the best that
you might hope for?
So the best lower
bound is due to E del.
And it's some construction,
some very specific construction,
which gives you a
bound that's something
like 2.21 to the n-th.
And the upper bound
is 3 to the n-th--
on the-- 3 minus
little 1 to the n-th.
So for a long time, it was
open whether the answer
should be basically
roughly like 3
to the n-th or some constant
less than 3 to the n-th.
And improvements on the
upper bound were very slow,
and/or some very difficult
works that nudge that down
below just a little bit.
And then a couple years
ago, a few years ago, there
was this incredible
breakthrough,
where in this paper that was
just a couple pages long,
they managed to significantly
improve the upper bound
to basically 2.76 to the n-th.
So this was an incredible
breakthrough that
happened just a few years ago.
And we'll talk about this
proof in a couple of lectures.
It turns out this proof,
which uses what's now
called the polynomial method--
so not Fourier analytic,
but a different method--
unfortunately does
not seem to generalize
to the original Roth's theorem.
In fact, you shouldn't
expect it to generalize
in a straightforward
way, because up there you
we know that you do not have a
power saving, whereas here you
have a power saving.
So the exponent goes down.
OK, so this is roughly the
history of this theorem.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: Do we have
to have [INAUDIBLE]??
YUFEI ZHAO: Yeah.
So I'll-- So I can tell you this
is known as a Croot-Lev-Pach.
So I'll say more about
it in a couple lectures.
But this for F3 is due to
Ellenberg and Gijswijt.
So I'll tell you more about
it in a couple lectures.
What I want to focus on today
is the Fourier analytic nature
of the proof that gives
you this bound up there,
3 to the n over n.
And it may seem like a
completely different topic
compared to what
we've been doing
so far in the course, which
is more about graph theory.
But I want you to
think about what
are the relationships
between what we'll see today
and what we've seen so far.
And there are lots
of connections.
So even though the
proof may superficially
look quite different,
many of these ideas
about quasirandomness versus
structure will come up.
And I want to present the
proof in a way that highlights
the similarities between
what we did previously
and this Fourier analytic proof.
So let's talk
about the strategy.
In the proof of the Szemerédi
graph regularity lemma,
we had the strategy that we
called the energy increment
strategy.
So you start-- you want
to find a good partition.
You start doing partitioning.
And you keep track of this
thing called the energy--
must go up at every step,
cannot go up forever,
so has a bounded
number of steps.
This strategy for Roth's theorem
is also an important strategy.
It's a variant of
energy increment,
but now density increment.
So we start with a set--
A subset of F3 to
the n-th, and we
would like to
understand something
about its structure
versus pseudorandomness
in a way that is similar
to when we discussed
the similar issue for graphs.
In particular, there
will be this dichotomy
that if A is in some
sense pseudorandom--
so earlier, we saw what it means
for a graph to be pseudorandom.
So now, what does it
mean for a subset of F3
to the n-th to be pseudorandom.
So we'll address that today.
If A pseudorandom--
OK, so the short answer is
that it is Fourier uniform--
in other words, all
Fourier coefficients small.
That's what pseudorandom
will refer to.
So then there is
a counting lemma.
And the counting lemma
will in particular
imply that A has lots of 3-APs.
So then you find your 3-AP.
If this is not the case, then--
so what's the opposite
of Fourier uniform--
is that A now has some
large Fourier coefficient.
And what we'll do is
to use this Fourier
coefficient to extract some
codimension 1 affine subspace--
it's also called a hyperplane--
where the density of A
goes up significantly,
if you restrict to
that sub hyperplane.
And you can repeat this process.
Now, restrict to this
hyperplane and ask yourself
the same question.
Is A, when restricted to this
hyperplane, pseudorandom?
In which case, we find APs.
Or is A restricted
to this hyperplane,
does it have a large
Fourier coefficient?
In which case, we
restrict further.
And each time you iterate, you
obtain a density increment.
And the density increment
cannot go on forever,
because your total
density is at most 1.
So the number of
steps must be bounded.
So that's the strategy.
So this should remind you
somewhat of the energy
increment strategy from
Szemerédi's regularity lemma,
although there are some
fundamental differences.
We're not doing partitionings.
Any questions about
this strategy?
OK.
I want to tell you
about Fourier analysis.
So probably, all of you
have seen some version
of Fourier analysis, maybe
in your calculus class
with Fourier series and whatnot.
So you play with formulas,
and solve some differential
equations.
So I want to give you
more than just a bunch
of ways about handling
Fourier coefficients,
a way to think about
Fourier analysis.
So think of this as a crash
course about Fourier analysis
from the perspective
of combinatorics.
And Fourier analysis,
I think, it's
much easier if you
work in a finite group,
in a finite abelian group,
which is what we're doing here.
Many of the
technicalities go away.
So we'll be looking specifically
at Fourier analysis in F3
to the n-th, although
the 3 can be any prime.
So it's really the same.
So the main actors
in Fourier analysis
are the Fourier characters.
The Fourier characters
are denoted gamma sub r.
And they're characters
on the group,
meaning that they
are maps which--
so they turn out, happen
to be homomorphisms for the
multiplicative group under--
so C under multiplication.
And they're indexed by r,
which also elements of F3
to the n-th.
So I'm going to be
fairly concrete here.
There are ways to do
this more abstractly.
But I'll be fairly concrete.
So it's defined by
gamma sub r evaluated
on x equals to omega raised
to r dot product x, where
here omega is a
third root of unity
and the dot is a dot product.
So--
So that's the definition
of the Fourier transform--
sorry, that's the definition
of the Fourier characters.
And once you have the
Fourier characters,
you can have this Fourier
transform, just defined
as follows.
If you start with a function--
let's say, a complex-valued
function on your space--
then I define the
Fourier transform
to be another function,
like that, defined
by the following formula.
So that's the formula for
the Fourier transform.
It is basically
the inner product
between F and the
Fourier character.
So let me make the
comment here, I
think this is actually a
pretty important comment,
about the normalization.
Now, when you first learn
Fourier transforms, usually
in the reals, there are all
these questions about what
number to put in the exponent.
Is it 2 pi?
Is it root 2 pi?
Is it some other thing?
And somehow, one answer
is better than the others.
And the same thing is
true here in groups.
So we'll stick with the
following convention--
and I want all of you to
stick with this convention,
otherwise, we'll confuse
ourselves to no end--
is that for a finite group--
actually, let me,
start of a board.
So the convention is
that, in a finite group,
the Fourier transform
is defined--
and more generally, anything
you do in the physical space,
we always use the
averaging measure.
Don't sum, always average
in the physical space.
And in the frequency
space, always use sums,
use the counting measure.
Keep this in mind.
Any of these questions
about normalization,
if you stick with
this convention,
things will become much easier.
So there won't be any of
these questions about when
you take the inverse
Fourier transform,
do I put an extra
factor in front or not,
if you stick with this
correct convention.
So with that convention
in mind, what the Fourier
transform really is is inner
product between F and a Fourier
character.
There are some
important properties
of the Fourier transform.
So let me go through a
few of the key properties
that we'll need.
The first one is pretty easy.
What is the meaning of the
0-th Fourier coefficient?
You plug it in, and you see that
it is just the average of F.
So 0-th coefficient
is the average of F.
The second fact goes
under one of two names,
and they're often
used interchangeably--
Plancherel or Parseval.
And it says that if you
look at the inner product
in the physical space,
then this product
is preserved, if you take
the Fourier transform.
But now, of course, you're
in the frequency space,
so you should sum instead
of doing the inner product.
So this identity can be proved
in a fairly straightforward way
by plugging in what the
definition is for the Fourier
transform.
This is a straightforward
computation
I'm not going to
do on the board,
but I highly encourage you
to actually do at home,
just to do it once to make sure
you understand how it goes.
But there is also a
more conceptual way
to understand this identity.
And that's because--
now, this is also
important to understand what
the Fourier transform is.
It's not just some magical
formula somebody wrote down,
like this is a very
natural operation.
It's because the characters,
the set of characters,
is an orthonormal basis.
So the Fourier characters
form an orthonormal basis.
As a result, what
the Fourier transform
is is a unitary change of basis.
You can check.
It's very
straightforward to check
that the Fourier
characters, indeed, form
a orthonormal basis, because--
well, you can evaluate the inner
product between two Fourier
characters.
So remember, in
the physical space,
we're always doing averaging.
And so now, I'll
just write down first
what I mean by
the inner product.
So that's the inner product.
And by the definition of
the Fourier character,
you have that.
So think about what
this expectation is--
unless r equals to s, in which
case, this expectation is 1.
Unless that is the
case, you always
have some coordinate
of x in the exponent.
So as you average over
all possibilities,
they average out to 0.
So this calculation shows you
that the Fourier characters
form a orthonormal basis.
And a basic fact you
know from linear algebra
is that if you do
a change of basis,
if you do a unitary
change of basis,
then inner product is preserved.
It's like a rotation.
It's the same-- so you're not
changing the inner product.
So the inner
product is preserved
under this change of basis.
And that's why
Plancherel is true.
Another important
thing is what's
known as the Fourier
inversion formula.
The Fourier transform tells
you how to go from a function
to the Fourier transform.
Well, now, if you are given
the Fourier transform,
how do you go back?
There's a formula
which tells you
that you can go back by the
following formula there.
So that's the Fourier
inversion formula.
It allows you to
do this inversion.
And again, it's one of
these formulas where
I encourage you to try it
out yourself by plugging
in the formula and expanding.
And it's pretty easy to check.
It's much easier in the finite
field setting, by the way.
So if you use the usual Fourier
transform on the real line,
there are some
technicalities even
to prove the Fourier inversion.
But in finite groups,
it's almost trivial.
You expand, and then you'll see.
So it's very easy to prove.
But you can also see this
Fourier inversion formula
more conceptually,
because you're
in a unitary change of basis.
So to go back, well, think about
what it means in linear algebra
to revert a unitary
transformation.
You simply multiply
the coefficients
with the coordinates.
Orthogonal, orthonormal
change of basis.
Finally, Fourier
transform behaves while
under convolution.
So by convolution, we
define the convolution
of two functions, f and g,
using the following formula.
And so then the claim is that
the Fourier transform behaves
very well under convolution.
It's basically multiplicative
under convolution.
So what this means
is, if I put in--
so it's pointwise
true everywhere.
Again, very easy proof, because
I just evaluate the left hand
side, see what--
plug in the formula for
the Fourier transform.
And I find it's that.
And now, I plug in the
formula for convolution.
So now, you can do a
change of variables.
And then you-- it's
not hard to see.
You eventually end up
at the right hand side.
So these are some
of the properties.
So there are
important properties
of the Fourier transform.
So this is something
that, whenever
you learn about
Fourier transform,
you always see these
few properties.
And so we'll use them.
But we'll also need
another property
that is specific to the
analysis of 3-term arithmetic
progressions.
So what does Fourier transform
have to do with 3-APs?
So we want to use it to
prove Roth's theorem.
So we better have
some tool that allows
us to analyze the number 3-APs.
And here is a key identity
relating Fourier with 3-APs.
And it's that, if you
have three functions,
then the following quantity,
which relates the number
of 3-APs--
So this function basically
counts the number 3-APs,
if your f, g, and h are
indicator functions of a set.
I want to express this formula
in terms of the Fourier
transforms of these functions.
The formula turns out
to be fairly simple,
that it is simply that.
So it's a single sum
over the r's of f hat
of r, g hat of minus
2r, and h hat of r.
You might wonder why I put a
minus 2 here, because minus 2
is r, and it looks
certainly much nicer
with just r in there.
And that is true.
This formula as written is
true for over any group.
And our proof will show it.
So it's not really about
F3 at all, but any group.
So let me prove this for you
in a couple of different ways.
So the first proof is
basically a straightforward no
thinking involved proof, as
in we apply these formula
for using either
Fourier inversion
or the inverse Fourier
transform, and plug it in,
and expand, and check.
So it's worth doing
at least this once.
So let's do this
together at least once.
But this something that is
a fairly straightforward
computation.
The left hand side
can be expanded
using Fourier inversion.
so r1 f hat r1 omega
to the minus r1
dot x, and sum over r2 g
hat r2 omega to the minus r2
dot x plus y, and
then finally sum
over r3 h hat of r3 omega to
the minus r3 dot x plus 2y.
So I'm using Fourier
inversion, replace f, g, and h
by their Fourier transforms.
Oh, sorry, there should be--
yeah, so no minus.
So now, we exchange
sums and expectations,
do a switch in the order of
summation, so r1, r2, r3 and f
hat of r1 g hat
of r2 h hat of r3.
And you have this expectation
over x and y and omega
of x dot r1 plus r2 plus r3.
In fact, I can even write
the x and y separately,
y omega to the y
dot r2 plus 2r3.
So just rearranging.
And now, you see
that as you take
expectation over x, this
expectation is equal to 1,
if r1 plus r2 plus r3 is
equal to 0, and 0 otherwise.
And likewise, the third
expectation is either 1 or 0,
depending on the
sums of r2 and r3.
So the only terms that
remain, after you take out
these 0's, are cases where
both these two equations
are satisfied.
And then you see that the only
remaining terms are basically
the ones given in the sum
on the right hand side.
OK?
So that's the proof.
Pretty straightforward, you
plug in Fourier inversion.
I want to show you a
different proof that
hopefully will be more
familiar and more conceptual.
Now, it doesn't involve carrying
through this calculation,
even though this is not
at all hard calculation.
But first, let me rewrite
the formula up there.
So in F3, it will be
convenient, and so
the formula is actually
slightly easier
to interpreting F3,
in F3, the identity
says that, if you
look at the quantity--
I need.
So let me give you a second
proof that works just in F3,
but you can modify it
to work in other groups.
But in F3, it's
particularly nice.
The left hand side, you
see, the left hand side,
I can rewrite it as
the following form,
where I sum over--
well, I take expectation over
all triples x, y, z that sum
to 0.
Because a 3-AP is the
same as three elements,
three points in the
vector space summing to 0.
But now, you see
that this quantity
is the same as the
convolution evaluated at 0--
so if you extend the definition
of convolution to more than one
func-- more than two functions.
But now, we apply
Fourier inversion.
And we find that--
OK.
So by Fourier inversion,
you have that.
But now, by the identity that
relates the Fourier transform
and inversion, you have that.
And that's the proof, because
minus 2 r is the same as r.
So it's shorter, because we're
using some properties here
about convolution and--
yeah, so about the convolution.
That formula up
there is, of course,
related to counting 3-APs.
Because if f, g, and h are
all indicators of some set,
then the left hand
side is the same
as basically the number of
triples of elements in A
whose sum is equal to 0.
And the right hand
side is the sum
of the third power of
the Fourier coefficients.
And this formula should
look somewhat familiar,
because we also used
this kind of formula
back when we discussed
spectral graph theory.
And remember, the third
moment of the eigenvalues
is the trace of the third
power, which counts closed
walks in Cayley graph.
So this is actually
the same formula.
So in the case if
A is symmetric,
let's say, then this is
the same as the formula
that counts closed
walks of length three
in the Cayley graph.
The point of this comment
is just to tell you
that Fourier
transform is somehow
it's not this brand new concept
that we've never seen before.
It is intimately tied
to many of the things
that we have seen earlier in
this course but in disguise.
So it is related to the
spectral graph theory
that we discussed at length
earlier in this course.
Now that we have the
Fourier transform,
I want to develop some
machinery to prove
Roth's theorem following
the strategy up there.
So let's take a quick break.
And then when we come back,
we'll prove Roth's theorem.
Any questions so far?
AUDIENCE: So for
this one, you said--
is it like we only
used the fact that it's
F3 to the n-th at the end of the
proof, like in that last step?
YUFEI ZHAO: OK.
So question is, where do we
use that in F3 to the n-th?
This formula here holds in
every finite abelian group,
if you use the correct
definition of Fourier
transform with the
averaging normalization.
So in the other formula where
you replace minus 2 by 1,
that requires F3.
But you can--
I mean, you can follow
the proof and come up
with a similar formula
for every equation.
So there's a general
principle here,
which I'll discuss
more at length
in a bit, that for
patterns that are
governed by a single equation--
in this case, 3-APs, x
minus 2y plus z equal to 0--
patterns that can be
governed by a single equation
can be controlled by
a Fourier transform.
So let's begin our proof,
the Fourier analytic proof
of Roth's theorem
in F3 to the n-th.
AUDIENCE: So at
the end, you said
it was going to be
connected with counting
the [INAUDIBLE] graph.
Does this mean that
the Fourier transform
of the indicator of A, those
are exactly the eigenvalues
of the Cayley graph?
Or is it like [INAUDIBLE]?
YUFEI ZHAO: OK, so you're asking
about the final step, where
we're talking about--
so I mentioned that
there was this connection
between counting walks in graphs
and spectral graph theory.
So you can check that, if you
have a subset A of an abelian
group, then the
Fourier transforms of A
are exactly the eigenvalues
of the Cayley graph.
AUDIENCE: So then
I guess, have we
done anything so far
that could have been done
in a spectral way yet?
Well, I guess, where is
the Fourier analysis better
than the spectral [INAUDIBLE]?
YUFEI ZHAO: OK.
Question, where is
the Fourier analysis
better than the spectral posts?
Well, let's see the proof first.
And then you'll see, yeah.
So there's no graphs anymore.
So we're going to work
inside F3 to the n-th.
But just like the proof
of regularity in counting,
we're going to have
a counting lemma.
So all of these are analytic.
And at this point, they should
be very familiar to you.
They may come in
a different form.
They may be dressed
in different clothing.
But it's still a counting lemma.
So let's see.
The counting lemma,
in this case,
says that if you are in the
setting of A F3 to the n-th--
and I'm going to
throughout write
the density of A as
alpha, then let me write,
let me define this lambda 3
of A to be the function which
basically counts 3-APs in
A but with the averaging
normalization.
So this is-- we
saw this earlier.
So the counting lemma says that
this normalized number of 3-APs
in A--
so including trivial 3-APs;
that's why this is a nice
analytic expression--
differs from what you might
guess based on density alone.
This difference should be small
if all the nonzero Fourier
coefficients of A are small.
So in this strategy, I said
that if-- so the counting
lemma tells you, if
A is Fourier uniform,
then it is pseudorandom.
And this is where it comes in.
If A has all small
Fourier coefficients,
then you have a counting
lemma, which tells you
that the counts
of A should not be
so different from the
guess based on density.
So the proof is very short.
It's based on the identity
that we saw earlier.
The 3-AP count of A by
the identity earlier
is simply the third power
of the Fourier transforms.
And all of these calculations
should be reminiscent,
because we've done these
kind of calculations
in some form or another
earlier in this course.
So we're going to
separate out the main term
and subsequent terms.
So the main term is the one
corresponding to r equals to 0.
So that's the density.
And all the other
terms I'm going
to lump together into this sum.
So we now know
that the difference
we're trying to bound
is upper bounded
by the third moment of the
absolute values of the Fourier
transform.
And I want to upper
bound this quantity here,
assuming that all of these
Fourier coefficients are small.
We've also done this kind
of calculations before.
So where have we
seen this before?
We saw this calculation
earlier in the class
with the 3 replaced by a 4.
So in counting four cycles
in a proof equivalent
of quasirandomness, we said
that, if all the eigenvalues
other than the top
one are small, then
you can count four cycles.
It's the same proof.
And remember, in
that proof, there
was a important trick,
where you do not uniformly
bound each term by the
max, because then you lose.
You lose by an extra factor
of n that you don't want.
So you only take out one factor.
So you take out one factor.
And you keep the rest in there.
In fact, I can be
more generous and even
throw the r equal
to 0 term back in.
And now, by Plancherel--
so by Plancherel/Parseval,
this here
is equal to the expectation
of the indicator
function of A squared.
So you take this--
you go back to physical space,
and that's simply the density.
So then that proves the theorem.
So the moral of the counting
lemma is the same as the one
that we've seen before
when we discussed graphs.
If you're in pseudorandom,
then you have good counting.
And here, pseudorandom
means having small Fourier
coefficients, uniformly
small Fourier coefficients.
So now, let's begin the
proof of Roth's theorem.
The Roth's theorem proof
will have three steps.
The first step, we will
observe that if you're
in the 3-AP-free set, then
there exists a large Fourier
coefficient.
Throughout, I'm going to
use uppercase N to denote
the size of the ambient group.
And specifically, we
will prove the following.
And also throughout, A is
a subset of F3 to the n-th
and with density alpha.
So I'll keep this convention
throughout this proof.
We will show that if A is
3-AP-free and N is at least 2
to the alpha to the minus 2--
so N is at least
somewhat large--
then there exists
a nonzero r such
that the r-th Fourier
coefficient is at least alpha
squared over 2.
If you're 3-AP-free,
free then provided
that you're working in a
large enough ambient space,
you always have some
large Fourier coefficient.
So the proof is
essentially-- well,
this claim is essentially a
corollary of counting lemma,
by the counting lemma.
And using the fact
that in a 3-AP-free
set, what is the
quantity lambda 3 of A?
Up there, you only have
the trivial 3-APs present.
So this quantity
lambda must then
be the size of A divided by N
squared or alpha over N, which
are precisely counting
the trivial 3-APs.
So by the counting
lemma, then we
have that the upper
bound on the right hand
side, which we now write
alpha max over nonzero r's, is
at least alpha cubed minus
the lambda 3 term, which
should be alpha
over N. So provided
that N is large enough--
big N is large enough--
then the trivial 3-APs should
not contribute very much.
So I can lower bound the
right hand side by, let's say,
alpha 3--
alpha cubed over 2.
So then you deduce
the conclusion.
I want you to think about
how this proof is related
to Szemerédi's graph
regularity lemma.
The analogy will break
down at some point.
But we've seen this
step before as well.
From lack of 3-APs, you
extract some useful information
and from this will
extract some structure.
And the structure here--
and this is where the
proof now diverges
from that of regularity--
having a large
Fourier coefficient
will now imply a density
increment on a hyperplane.
Specifically, if you have--
so keeping the same
convention as before,
if the Fourier
coefficient of A at r
is at least delta
for some nonzero r,
then A has density at least
alpha plus delta over 2
when restricted to a hyperplane.
So if you have a large
Fourier coefficient,
then I can pass down to a
smaller part of the space
where the density of A
goes up significantly.
To see why this is
true, let's go back
to the definition of the
Fourier coefficient, the Fourier
transform.
So recall that Fourier transform
is given by the following
formula, where I'm looking at
this expectation over points
in F3 to the n-th together
with indicator of A multiplied
by this Fourier character.
And you see that this
function here, it
is constant on cosets of
the hyperplane defined
by the orthogonal
complement of r.
So the value of this dot
product is this constant
on the three hyperplanes.
So I can rewrite this
expectation simply
as 1/3 of alpha 0
plus alpha 1 omega
plus alpha 2 omega squared,
where alpha 0, alpha 1, alpha 2
are the densities of A on
the three cosets of r perp.
So group this expectation
into these three hyperplanes.
So now, you see that
if this guy is large,
then you should expect that
alpha 0, alpha 1, and alpha 2
are not all too
close to each other.
So if they were all equal to
each other, you should get 0.
But you should not expect them
to be too close to each other.
In particular, we would want to
say that one of them goes up--
is much bigger than alpha.
So one of these, they must
be much bigger than alpha.
That's an elementary inequality.
This is something that I'm
sure I give you five minutes
you can figure out.
But let me show you a
small trick to show this.
And the reason for this trick
is because in next lecture, when
we look at Roth's theorem
over the integers,
we'll need this extra trick.
And the trick here is this.
We now know that because
of the hypothesis,
3 delta is lower bound to
the absolute value of alpha 0
plus alpha 1 omega plus
alpha 2 omega squared.
OK, so note here that the
average of the three alphas
is equal to the original alpha
by definition of density.
So this inner sum I can
read write like that.
So the sum of the three
groups of unity add up to 0.
And now, I apply
triangle inequality
to extract the terms.
So now, you should
already deduce
that one of the alphas i's
has to be significantly
larger than alpha.
And has to be
significantly different,
but there are only three times.
One of them has to be
significantly larger.
But let me do this
one extra trick, which
we'll need next time,
which is that let
me add an extra term like
that, which sums out to 0.
But now, you see that each
summand is always nonnegative.
So one of the--
so there exists some j such
that delta lower abounds
the j-th summand.
And if you look at what
that means, then alpha lower
bounds the j-th summand.
So in particular, this sum
here should be nonnegative.
So you have that.
Good.
So we obtained a density
increment of this hyperplane.
And finally, I want to iterate
this density increment.
So I want to iterate
this density increment--
so summary so far
is that we have--
so if A is 3-AP-free with
density alpha and N at least 2
to the alpha to
the minus 2, then A
has density at least alpha
plus alpha squared over 4
on some hyperplane.
So you combine step one and step
two, we obtain this conclusion.
Well, I can now
repeat this operation.
So I can repeat by restricting
A to this hyperplane.
If A is originally 3-AP-free,
I restrict it to a hyperplane,
it's still 3-AP-free.
So I can keep going.
I can keep going provided
that my space is still
large enough, because I still
need this lower bound on F.
So don't forget this one here.
So I can keep going
as long as N is--
so I'm using N sub
j to denote what
happens after the j-th step.
I can keep going as long
as this is still satisfied.
But of course, you cannot
keep on going forever,
because the density is bounded.
So density cannot exceed 1.
So these two will give you a
bound on the total dimension.
So let's work this out.
So let alpha i
denote the density
after step i in this iteration.
And we see from over here that
you start with density alpha,
and each step you go up by an
increment, which is basically
what--
so you go up by some increment.
And you want to know,
if you start with alpha,
how many steps at most can you
take before you blow out 1.
So can you give me some bound?
So what's the maximum--
at most, how many steps?
So we know that the
density cannot exceed 1.
AUDIENCE: 4 by alpha squared.
YUFEI ZHAO: So you see
that you have at most 4
over alpha squared steps,
because density is at most 1.
And if you plug this in,
you get something which
is not quite what I stated.
So it turns out that
if you plug this in,
you find that alpha is--
you find that the
size of A is at most 3
to the n-th over square root n.
So let me do a
little bit better,
so then simply seeing
that this term here is
at least alpha squared over 4.
And the point is that
when you increment,
you increment faster and faster.
So I can use that
to give a better
bound on the number of steps.
And here's the way to see it.
So let me-- we can do better.
So starting at alpha, I then
now ask, how many steps do you
need to take before it doubles?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: It goes up
by alpha squared over 4.
So it doubles after at
most 4 over alpha steps.
And at which point
this alpha, new alpha,
becomes at least the original--
twice the original alpha?
But now, you keep going.
How many times does it
take to double again?
2 over alpha, because the
alpha became twice as much.
So it doubles again after
at most 2 over alpha steps.
And then you keep going.
The next iteration
is 1 over alpha.
So in total-- so you see that
we must stop after at most 8
over alpha steps.
So the number of
times it doubles,
actually it decreases by
at least half each time.
So now, we know that--
we see that the--
so you keep on going.
So you must stop after at
most 8 over alpha steps.
What is the final density
when you have to stop,
because when are
you forced to stop?
You are forced to stop
if you run out of space.
So you're forced to stop
when you run out of space.
So if the process
terminates after m steps--
so we're at density alpha m,
so then the final subspace
has size less than 2 to the
alpha m raised to minus 2,
which is--
So now, I use this bound alpha.
So the initial N is
upper bounded by what?
So how many steps did you take?
You took at most 8
over alpha steps.
Each of those steps, you pass
down to codimension what?
You lose a dimension
for each step.
And the final subspace
has at least this--
has at most that much space.
So the final dimension is this,
basically log 1 over alpha.
So put them together, we see
that the size of the space
originally is at
most 1 over alpha.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Should this
be a lower case n?
YUFEI ZHAO: Thank you.
Yeah.
This should be a lower
case n, so the dimension.
Good.
And OK, so then that's the
conclusion, that the density
alpha is big O of 1 over n.
That proves the main
theorem for today,
so Roth's theorem
over F3 to the n-th.
So we went through this
Fourier analytic proof.
Next lecture, we will see
the same proof again but done
in the integers for interval.
And there, there are
some difficulties
that we don't see over here.
Because in the
finite field space,
in the finite field
model, there's
this very nice idea of
looking at subspaces,
so looking at hyperplanes.
Each Fourier coefficient gets
you down to one dimension less.
But when you're working
in the integers,
there are no
subspaces you can use.
So we'll be looking
at ways to get around
the lack of subspaces.
And this is why I
said in the beginning
that the finite
field model is often
a very good playground for
additive combinatorics type
techniques, especially
Fourier analytic techniques.
Because in the additive--
in all of these
techniques, they just
come out to be much cleaner.
If you're working in a
finite field setting,
you have nice subspaces,
you have Fourier
transform in a very clean way.
The Fourier transform
always takes, in this case,
one of three values.
Everything's very clean.
Everything's very simple.
And you get to
see the idea here.
You get to see the sense
of the increment argument.
But once you
understand those ideas
and you're willing to do
more work, then oftentimes,
you can bring those
ideas to other settings,
to other abelian
groups, to the integers,
for instance, but with
more work in the--
there are some extra ingredients
that you need to use.
I mentioned that
there was a bound--
OK, so initially--
So next time, we'll see that.
Next time, we'll see what
happens over the integers.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: OK, great.
So question is why the process
must stop after at most 8
over alpha steps?
So you know that the density
doubles after this many steps,
doubles again after
that many steps.
So eventually, if it
keeps on doubling,
it cannot keep on
doubling forever.
So this process cannot
keep on doubling forever.
So it must stop--
so cannot double more than log
base 2 of 1 over alpha times.
And that point,
you have to stop.
So how many steps
have you taken?
Well, you sum this
geometric series.
So this-- and the
next thing is that you
sum this geometric series.
And that geometric series
sums to 8 over alpha.
Great.
So let's finish here.
So next time, we'll see Roth's
proof of Roth's theorem.